You know what hurts?
Pain.
But why does pain have to hurt so much, and
could we maybe dial it back a bit if the pain
gets too intense?
Thanks to a recent study from Stanford University,
we may just be able to control how we experience
pain.
As much as it hurts, pain is useful in most
cases.
It lets us know that what’s happening is
bad for us or when something is seriously
wrong.
Without it, we would easily injure ourselves
or not realize our bodies aren’t functioning
as they should.
In fact, there is a rare condition called
Congenital Insensitivity to Pain with Anhidrosis,
or CIPA, and people suffering from it can
break bones without even knowing or overheat
easily, which is especially dangerous when
they’re children.
So pain is a good thing.
Or at least the ability to feel it is.
But there are those on the other extreme of
the spectrum who experience chronic pain.
For them, it mostly serves no purpose other
than discomfort and agony.
Drugs like opioids can dull the pain, but
they can be extremely addictive and impact
other parts of the brain.
So identifying exactly which neurons control
the discomfort that comes with pain can lead
to new drugs that allow people to still know
they’re hurting, but without the actual
hurt.
That’s where a 2019 study published in the
journal Science by researchers at Stanford
University comes in.
The researchers probed mouse brains for where
pain was felt, and when I say probed I mean
that literally.
They attached miniature microscopes to the
mice’s heads and observed their brains in
real time!
While the mouse was just walking around, doing
mouse stuff!
The scientists’ target was the amygdala,
which in humans is a small almond-shaped area
associated with processing emotions.
But it’s really dark inside a mouse’s
brain, so to see what was going on, researchers
introduced a fluorescent protein that lit
up whenever neurons fired.
With microscopes and glow-teins in place,
researchers started poking and prodding the
mice to see what area lit up when they were
in discomfort.
They found about 150 neurons in a region called
the basolateral amygdala that sparked up when
the mouse was in pain, and glowed more brightly
when the pain was more intense.
But the scientists weren’t looking for neurons
that signaled pain, but the ones that signaled
it was unpleasant.
To find out if the neurons they’d spotted
were the ones they were looking for, the researchers
created chemical switches that allowed them
to turn the neurons on and off.
When the researchers switched the neurons
off, the mice could still sense pain and would
show it by displaying their usual reflex to
withdraw from painful stimuli.
But they didn’t show signs the pain was
unpleasant, like by avoiding the stimuli or
licking their paws.
Essentially they could still feel pain, they
just didn’t mind so much.
When the researchers switched off the same
neurons in mice with chronic pain, they found
the mice didn’t mind the light touches that
used to harm anymore.
If neurons that work the same way can be found
in humans, and if these neurons have unique
receptors, then it might be possible to develop
drugs that target them and turn down their
activity.
That would be huge news for sufferers of chronic
pain, or even those in intense pain who might
otherwise be prescribed drugs that are addictive
and imprecise.
It’s probably still a ways off, so in the
meantime do your best not to hurt yourself.
So, would you let scientists attach a microscope
to your brain if it meant making a major breakthrough?
Let us know in the comments!
And for more on the science of your brain,
check out this video.
Thanks for watching, and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker.